mad flavor at my man Santana's what's
this here oh yeah what is this a nice
guy and what's the best ooh
if I want to see the [__] devil the
devil came in here right now says I want
to [__] see Jesus it's one of those
purples they'll give me headaches it's a
stronger thicker Oh what else you know
what I like I like a little mix
something to get me going like I got ya
pick me up with a [__] left hook pop
we'll take a look at this sexy fun
animal right here
are you kidding that's 20 life no-parole
you know you should take your home make
you listen to a leader records is Louie
tough it's the same boo you had last
week maybe all right let me get a G ball
to rule that what else you got what else
you like something strength I want to
see the devil it's Monday my wife don't
get home till 6 o'clock GDP which one
her no no no Purple's I got headaches
what about the Sour Diesel this is how
algae hydrate would you like that dude
let me get a Jeep or solid diesel over
here Magnolia between violence is the
spot right here my man Santana looking
he's getting better look at all the
[__] time right that Santana the
first out become mad flavors well coming
at you stay black